neighbors in one part of the valley
really concerned after someone was shot
to death it happened at the intersection
of grand canyon and rochelle and that's
where we find 8 news now reporter sally
jeremiel joining us live with more
denise and brian that victim identified
as 20-year 28-year-old jacob huey from
north las vegas and people who live in
the area say they are in shock something
like this happened here
oh we're very good everything is very
very safety for me yeah sometimes i walk
here everything's good i like here
people who live in this neighborhood say
it's a safe place to be that's why they
were shocked to learn someone was shot
to death early sunday morning the
coroner identified the victim as jacob
huey there was two men who approached
each other in the parking lot had an
argument and during the argument the
deceased had actually struck the suspect
one time that caused the suspect to pull
out a gun and fire multiple times
striking and killing the victim police
say the suspect then got into a vehicle
and took off some say while they're
surprised they believe crime is on the
rise everywhere we've noticed as the
valley has grown suburban
stretch
we're seeing more
transients
vagrants kind of camping out in this lot
right behind us mansell says it's the
overall growth of the valley having an
impact in his neighborhood being here
for this long you hear it in other
neighborhoods you hear about it and yeah
of course it was a surprise i think it's
just a random act
i don't think it's a regular thing that
goes on
in this particular area but i think it's
happening throughout the valley
out here live there have been no arrests
yet if you have any information you are
urged to contact police immediately
steli haramiyo live local now